comes full circle it almost sounds like
you eat her second brilliant oh no he's
tugged into 3d Pisces what we're gonna
do is when we're in front of the green
screen we're gonna dumb over the line so
we're just gonna be standing there still
and just going this is a moment where
yelling yeah then we're gonna dumb over
the lines later oh yeah I want to get
closer to dragon ball in our parody than
anything like all they know that's
dragon ball but they see the movie no
people know this jacket know what's
going on here action so shitty movie you
think you piss off a legion of fans
would be a misunderstanding of use of so
it's material
rolling
[Laughter]
it's the yugi-boy
oh no he's turned into 3d pipes
oh my god I'm hearing
oh no he's turned into 3d pipes one more
for safety
yeah
okay so we just shot there's a slumming
offeri on the couch here okay so these
swings are very cool wings and
everything but I mean this is how much
was on the couch this is just from me
brushing the couch and that's how much
was on there so I almost fucking
business like no I got shooting the
second because it's like a free scene so
yeah they look great there's still some
on there but it was amazing all right
Lawrence you ready
I think you've peaked officially peeps
yeah who needs screwattack when you got
this this is where the money happens
right that's gonna be fun this is gonna
be I I didn't have to dress up but yeah
cuz Doug sent me the script he was
asking me are there any adjustments that
need to be made and I saw that he had
you originally as Vegeta
and Martinez Goku and I'm like I'm like
wait a sec it was a joke yeah me too I
was like subverted like yeah I'm gonna
roll with it
I shouldn't yeah I'm probably she left
it like that but I'm like you do know he
plays coccoon the abridged series like
hey
I'm just gonna go okay yeah do it I'll
do it I trust you Doug
yeah I'm like all right nobody what good
is cuz it's funny cuz I like I do loads
of light I've done a couple sketches and
they say I'll do an American voice and
then and then eventually they say we
want some really peppy so do you want me
to just do the Goku voice just say that
me like 10 minutes ago Malcolm told me
when I was like another scoop you say
you know you might want to put
Lawrence's Goku right that's very
logical yes I was just saying I thought
it was like a joke I had to write
something like three or four scripts
that week it's one of those things so
I'm just go and go and going it
sometimes he just missed something
really obvious or you rewrite stuff like
you know you're so they're just like oh
yeah he thought it was a swerving I did
[Laughter]
all right okay so you give me Crillon
yeah I get the bigwig anime is so weird
is it Jaden Smith selfie sessions yeah
did he so like I feel like everyone's in
on the joke except Jaden that's high the
transformation begins
oh man it's great it's never too late
my brother's obsessed with anime so he's
gonna start like getting me into it
we're gonna start like vlogging some yes
anime stuff so I'll hunt you up okay
yeah hit me up all right so we have Goku
yes
it never they never looked like la jeune
no at first when I saw this actual thing
I went I had hope right and I just went
like oh no no this is not gonna fill
this is not gonna fill out my head
because as you can see look yeah that's
like I'm not gonna fit my head I don't
that fits anyone's head it's like a
child yeah well nobody in a dog costume
yes and you know my partner would say I
have the forehead of Jimmy Neutron oh no
my head is too big but you did a command
me that's because it's so full of dreams
yes goes for a Dragonball knowledge
desired result that's the main thing
yeah exactly it's got the whole
aesthetic thing how did you get the
boots
I remember in looking at it looks
what did you're supposed to oh you're so
looks like that what's his okay yes
honey but Jesus character is the spiky
one with the widow's peak okay yeah but
I mean the shoes yeah the shoes are not
that bad I don't cost you question for
you Tamra you're I think you ever seen a
way with chin strap yeah that is
ambitious
okay new making it that it was way too
small for anyone so Oh God it was show
yeah yeah it looked like a weird
sideburn in what the in Luke yeah maybe
so you just loop it around your ears
it's like they made a bunch of them and
they were like oh oh just for the heck
of a train on sideways okay let's see if
we can salvage it a mohawk we have so
much the one joke that I thought of when
you suggested watching a movie again and
and I tried but it was different this is
about the only joke I could think of was
tornado v Chenery name is such because
much like evolution many people pretend
it is oh yeah that's that's true this is
I'm going for Vegeta three after the
time chamber
excu right you wouldn't know it from
that one scene in that one episode that
people sleep because they were bored I'm
gonna be a truly exactly you gotta be a
true fan I think three of us but my
chest is completely covered yep and so I
save get the singing armor pretty cool
is absolutely ridiculous but now with
the body armor I'm like your silence
only enables your guiltiness then I will
show you the meaning of pain you can't
fight this evil alone you need a
wrecking ball to understand this outrage
oh yeah that's wonderful
Lawrence on the show they don't have any
light where the fingers really in the
forefront do they do
they really do do that they most of the
time it's like almost like panning shots
like yeah paddy shot to the face then
sometimes they might be well when they
do great because I want to do anyone are
you in yeah usually it's like they
actually focus on the arm that go then
patented person yeah like they just like
have throw some more sideways then you
see the hand yeah cut okay so you get a
close-up of the hand you can turn them
oh okay oh this there you go yeah
perfect fun okay let me do the focus
here real fast hands to accentuate point
yeah you're right there's a lot of
panning I just thought about that yeah
that's a lot of panning to say obviously
needles have this dad down right
[Laughter]
okay okay I think just like putting it
that way it's like yeah
[Laughter]
even from me but I'm smart enough to
know while you two are bitching like
pansies your opponent is building his
power even from the right anime baby but
I'm smart enough to know while you two
are bitching like pansies your
opponent's you're not even from the
right baby but I'm smart enough to know
while you two are bitching like pansies
your opponent is Billie and that's where
we come in okay ready and one two three
that's where we come in Massa coax from
Dragon Ball Z abridged and little
kuriboh from Yukio abridged that's right
a Japanese anime dubbed by Americans
analyzed by two prints it makes a
okay alright y'all ready and action
that's right and I was supposed to get
my bed okay ready and one two three
that's where we come in Massa COEX from
Dragon Ball Z a bridge and little
kuriboh from yugioh abridged that's
right
two Brits Bach okay the Dragon Ball
franchise is one of the most popular
animes ever made taking place in a
parallel dimension it follows the
adventures of goku and his friends
defending earth against intergalactic
aliens androids and other various evils
who really like to yell with spin-offs
including Dragon Ball Z Dragon Ball Z
Kai Dragon Ball GT and Dragon Ball super
there's over 700 episodes of this
franchise and it's still going so
naturally it made sense for Hollywood to
try and capitalize on it and make a
movie for Americans how did it go okay
dude goes dude ghost in the shell' do
bad yes then this dev really all right
ready yeah it goes in the shell do bed
yes and this day really bad dick ghost
in the shell do bed yes and this did
really bad one more
dick ghost in the shell' do bed yes
enlisted really bad really doesn't look
like a Goku well as a white man I'm
offended
[Laughter]
[Music]
doesn't look like a goq well as a white
man I'm offended you are yes
stereotyping like that I for one embrace
culturally diverse names that in no way
raise any questions or seem distracting
wow I really didn't think this with the
angle you guys would lean of course of
course
[Laughter]
do you like my assassin uniform and
makes you do you like my assassin
uniform and make sure you know that I
have breasts
do you like my assassin uniform sure you
know that I have to you know what
sounded like Michael Jackson there first
cuz they calling geek oh yeah oh is that
a typo is you yeah
yeah-oh doesn't give us a bus Goku there
yeah okay yeah just a Goku sir funny by
the way how in the show Goku was a child
prodigy and he he can't even lied to
goddamn candle well that's because he's
not properly horny evaded love that's
because he's not properly horny baited
evaded okay
I swear that happens to all the guys
know all guys I swear but I swear that
happens to all guys a little bit I swear
I swear that happens to all guys good
one
I swear that happens to all guys let's
do that one on camera no I swear that
happens to all guys look I swear that
happens to all guys okay hashtag popular
phrase hashtag popular phrase I like the
first one doing with hashtag popular
phrase hashtag popular phrase
that still works it hashtag popular
phrase oh no he's turned into 3d pipes
[Music]
yeah a something like that dragon what
do you know about dragon ball that I
don't what do you know about wrecking
ball that I don't grunt grunt grunt
grunt grunt grunt grunt grunt grunt get
out of here Yugi get out of here Yugi
blow you're not even from the right
anime get out of here you keep low
you're not getting from the right anime
get out of here you keep low you're not
from the right anime get out of here you
keep low you're not even from the right
anime my god he's going stupid saying my
God he's going stupid saying great now I
will fight you by doing the same move
repeatedly and you doing the same done
repeatedly now fight you by doing the
same move repeatedly and you doing the
same dodge repeatedly now I'll fight you
fight doing the same move repeatedly and
you doing the same dodge repeatedly now
I will fight you by doing the same move
repeatedly and you doing the same does
repeatedly
agreed
let dueling sites join forces just this
once agreed let dueling sites join
forces justice was done let's go horny
Goku that's me oh man it's like it's
only when I was doing the voice of like
shit like your voice really funny and
your butt are both arms are high like my
normal voices and you guys doing the
voices yeah cuz your voice is really
funny I think hearing - right this way
they're gonna be like Christ that's one
of the reasons why need is such a
different voice but Crillon when he did
the character like this yeah with the
same range yeah yeah I think that'll
work
cuz yeah I'm hearing these voices Oh
funny
they made him sound more like Courage
the Cowardly Dog things I do for love
yeah currently but things I do for love
yeah
you
[Music]